we're told alexa is riding on a ferris
wheel her height above the ground in
meters is modeled by h of t
where t is the time in seconds and we
can see that
right over here now what i want to focus
on this video
is some features of this graph and the
features we're going to focus on
actually the first of them
is going to be the midline so pause this
video and see if you can figure out the
midline
of this graph or the midline of this
function and then we're going to think
about what it actually represents
well alexis starts off at five meters
above the ground and then she goes
higher and higher higher gets as high as
25 meters and then goes back as low as
five meters
above the ground and as high as 25
meters and what we can view the midline
as is the
midpoint between these extremes or the
average of these extremes
well the extremes are she goes as low as
5 and as high as 25.
so what's the average of 5 and 25 well
that would be 15.
so the midline would look something like
this and i'm actually going to keep
going
off the graph and the reason is is to
help us think about what does that
midline even represent and one way to
think about it is
it represents the center of our rotation
in this situation or how how high above
the ground is the center
of our ferris wheel and to help us
visualize that let me draw a ferris
wheel
so i'm going to draw a circle with this
as the center
and so the ferris wheel would look
something like would look something like
this
and it has some type of maybe support
structure
so the ferris wheel might look something
like that and this height above the
ground
that is 15 meters that is what the
midline
is representing now the next feature
i want to explore is the amplitude
pause this video and think about what is
the amplitude of this oscillating
function right over here and then we'll
think about what does that represent
in the real world or where does it come
from in the real world
well the amplitude is the maximum
difference or the maximum magnitude away
from that midline
and you can see it right over here at
actually right when alexis
or alexa starts we have
starting 10 meters below the midline
10 meters below the center and this is
when
alexa is right over here she is 10
meters
below the midline and then after
a looks like 10 seconds she is
right at the midline so that means that
she's right
over here maybe the ferris wheel is
going this way at least in my
imagination it's going
clockwise and then after another 10
seconds she is at 25 meters
so she is right over there
and you can see that she is right over
there i drew that circle
intentionally of that size and so we see
the
amplitude in full effect 10 meters below
to begin the midline and 10 meters above
and so it's the maximum displacement or
the maximum
change from that midline
and so over here it really represents
the radius of our ferris wheel
10 meters and then from this part she
starts going
back down again and then over here she's
back where to where she started
now the last feature i want to explore
is the notion of a period what is the
period
of this periodic function pause this
video and think about that
well the period is how much time does it
take to complete one cycle
so here she's starting at the bottom and
let's see after 10 seconds not at the
bottom yet after 20 seconds not at the
bottom yet after 30 seconds not at the
bottom yet and then here she is after 40
seconds
she's back at the bottom and about to
head up again
and so this time right over here that
40 seconds that is the period and if you
think about what's going on over here
she starts over here 5 meters above the
ground after
10 seconds she is right over here and
that corresponds to this point right
over here
after 10 more seconds she's right over
there that corresponds to that point
after 10 more seconds she's over here
that corresponds to that
and after 10 more seconds or total of 40
seconds
she is back to where she started so the
period
in this example shows how long does it
take to complete
one full rotation now we have to be
careful sometimes when we're trying to
visually inspect
the period because sometimes it might be
tempting to say
start right over here and say okay we're
15 meters above the ground
all right let's see we're going down now
we're going up again
and look we're 15 meters above the
ground maybe this
20 seconds is a period but when you look
at it over here
it's clear that that is not the case
this point represents
this point at being 15 meters above the
ground going down
that's going to get us to this point and
then after another 10 seconds we get
back over here
notice all this is measuring is half of
a cycle going halfway around
in order to go all the way around not
only do we have to get to the same exact
height
but we have to be moving in the same
direction we're at 15 meters and going
down
here we're 15 meters and going up so we
have to keep going another 20 seconds in
order to be going
in order to be 15 meters in the air and
going
down